reaches up for the rebound paces up
fancy pass and it's down
how about again Ben Simmons shown it
behind the back you're just born with it
it's the sixth sense huh
great motion and the bucket falls he
looks like he's gonna throw hand off
there and then he catches Allen in the
forty seven seven school great feed then
Simmons with the dime somebody waits for
it
flip bowling pass to traffic you know
how he got it up to him Simmons
[Applause]
assist controls five-on-five scrimmages
all right the Commissioner will be
speaking when that happens we will take
you to it on NBA TV he never looks at
him and that's what makes that play
works a lot of times in the defender
you're looking at the eyes of the
offensive player and the Warriors a
coach got stuck in the air and the wall
right the passing ability on display for
homes and the finish out of transition
watching well this has been a big
interesting him came wet came over late
in the season was really good for you so
that's a lot of veteran player 5 that's
what Ben Simmons could do I mean he
could make plays that other guys can't
even see but look at this pass here just
write and strive that's when you can
make those kinds of Patrick game
emotionally you can't bike he's got to
stay stronger than that nice
that's good job to get him a layup good
by indeed the last time there in the
plows was 2012 got to the second round
that year and are some of the basket
Simmons with the dish and a three-point
opportunity it's out there with Robert
Covington JJ Redick this guy Dario
sharukh goes backdoor to Simmons one
more two and feed that my friends is
biscuit ball here's the ball move in a
nice little behind the back pass
six is aggressive defensively and quite
Franklin Cavaliers out of sync Simmons
nicely done for Covington it'll be a
timeout Tehran loo really good offensive
teams they don't have a lot of shooting
as Boca with the night off the set play
but I guess if you see the mismatch you
have to be ready to help high school
year from their lives as well Saint
Anthony's watchers say they hear
Anderson it'll count for a three yes you
can count it for Justin Anderson wary of
2004 the 19 point leads impressive but
how about the 31 points give it up to
the Spurs you love playing with guys
like that because those are the guys
that keep you out on the floor to play
victim ps8 gorgeous look by Ben Simon
Mountain Dew rising stars with the
players first and last day and voting is
open now for the MVP Simmons
[Applause]
Felicio lost it we should stop dribbles
boy Simmons
delivering to him be pretty play for
shards Ben Simmons right now with eyes
and back of his head he's got six
assists already Simmons great look and
that'll be the triple-double for Ben
Easter Sunday from Charlotte the Sixers
are looking for their 10th straight win
Robert Covington compliments of Ben
Simmons Simmons between the legs it's
heretic
[Applause]
your dribble to get you somewhere how
about using the dribble to get the crowd
going
nice by 2jj then in the crowd love
dribble handoffs so they're difficult
and remember both of these teams make
eleven
again not stuck under the basket now
Simmons it's a five on four wait slow to
get back there's coming too by Ben
Simmons most averaging a triple-double
in this playoff series and he sets up
Covington beautiful chance to slip two
spots Oh between the legs not just
between his own legs sevens but between
Horford's legs as well yeah look at this
okay I'm gonna throw it to everybody if
you turn my legs chakras that saw three
of me that is a well it's the
unwillingness and the inability as well
turnover though about Boston off Simmons
in transition
[Applause]
oh here's Simmons coming up with eternal
the great look at that I didn't think
I'd get that excited in the music game
finds a streaky Markel along the
baseline that's just smart basketball
Simmons just takes a little play by
Simmons man Marcus Morris number three
look at that pass nice finish how about
the finish there's the cut my fault once
you guys playing together not a lot of
court time between these two last year
Simmons accelerates down Redick in a
crowd struggled in the first half it's
young for three and Simmons has it for
the Sixers nice spot of Covington who
throws it down the fifth assist of the
game for Simmons about how Roberts
defense sets up his offense that time a
good challenge on tre
Simmons give it go within feet and
Joelle promptly throws it down Zeller
just v three he's taken this year he
made one Wow nice hookup between Simmons
and Butler length from one end to the
other Jojo to Ben right before he gets
to have 40 spots of streaking Jimmy it's
about Serina need to communicate
especially on the defensive end and why
not on the bench as well Clark my
compliments of Ben Simmons by the way
for Ben his first assist they're out
there shooting just 5 of 16 from the
field
Simmons all beautiful whoops from
Simmons and the butler the Simmons
you've got to find a way to slow the
freight train down because if he gets by
and then at opens up your options and a
really good job by Butler to get behind
the defense Danny Green law you can't
let him walk up into that mic he's too
smooth and you want to talk about a guy
who built this game that's one guy right
there is a nice little back cut by
Shannon it sloughing off kind of defense
they don't get in your face they don't
pressure the ball that plug Butler
it's for three got it not use that as an
excuse and coach Snyder told me today he
said we just forgot who we are
Joey they're sort of at
pathetic defense looks a certain way for
profligate Ewoks
JoEllen beats seventh in the NBA in
blocks Simmons
/ Bolden you complete on by the Sixers
who got the weight Nepal well this is
what prep round wants to great rotation
and your defense helping your offense by
taking the load off buckets in
transition that first thing he mentioned
was a wing defender and I think Dyer
Smith would have gotten some minutes
this year to adjust that as Simmons
delivering it beautifully to McConnell
for a store consistent i'll ago take a
look at Ben and exactly what he's able
to do in the post saw TJ out of the
corner of his right eye
[Applause]
the rant misses and it's popular he runs
it down
Perry hits the deck
[Applause]
Channel four three oh nice Santa by
Simmons afonso McKenna is time green
lurking to help behind the back blue
[Music]
green steps under and trying to land
that's a heck of a pass by Simmons a
jump hook right here and I see what
draymond Green is talking about how
Indiana very methodical of take their
time they'll run pick-and-roll they'll
run dribble handoff and you've got to
keep them out of the paint
great pass by Simmons he times it to
Harris for the moment I know this is
where they're they're at their best you
know Simmons right out there what close
to eight assists again he'll find
somebody final 3:30 before half-time is
a maestro
green flops no whistles Simmons what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content